ottawa se prépare à recevoir de la
visite inhabituelle les barricades sont
prêtes l'accès au parlement et restreint
les premiers manifestants pour leur
entrée et certains établissent même leur
campement devant le parlement
génératrice de mel watt au gaz cet homme
de sorel tracy demandent la fin des
restrictions sanitaires et il est prêt à
rester aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra
ça fera des semaines on restait sur dix
semaines
[Musique]
et deux femmes a ralenti le dos
si la plupart des protestataires
promettent un rassemblement sans grabuge
d'autres font des déclarations qui
laissent perplexe au regard des
arrestations civile pacifique la police
d'ottawa les liens qu'elle est prête à
déposer des accusations contre quiconque
agissant de manière violente
c'est un prélude à l'imposante
manifestation de la fin de semaine les
autorités refuse de s'avancer sur le
nombre de manifestants attendus à ottawa
chose certaine des kilomètres de camions
sont en route vers la capitale evs ont
paralysé le centre-ville
des centaines de poids lourds et de
véhicules séparés en différents convois
approche d'ottawa en provenance québec
de l'ontario et des maritimes notamment
[Musique]
élément déclencheur a été la vaccination
obligatoire des camionneurs imposée par
ottawa à la mi janvier une semaine plus
tard les etats unis ont emboîté le pas
comme prévu depuis le mouvement s'est
élargi protestation contre les mesures
sanitaires certains surfer sur la vague
nous faisons de bataille pour changer
l'opinion publique et s'assurer que plus
de canadiens qui s'aperçoivent tout
comme nous que ces mesures autoritaires
n'ont aucun effet sur la propre
propagation du virus le chef
conservateur erin o'toole a rencontré
des camionneurs comme il l'avait promis
mais loin des journalistes alors que des
partis comme le bloc québécois
choisissent de prendre leurs distances
de la manifestation ça va être plus de
manifestations anti vaccins pour autre
chose pour pour les droits des
camionneurs ou des choses comme ça la
menace c'est pas la vaccination la
menace et la coved 19 le gouvernement
trudeau continue de défendre ses
politiques nous sommes tous dans le même
convoi nous sommes à un convoi pour
sortir le plus rapidement possible de la
coved 19 mai à ce moment si ce n'est pas
cet appel à l'unité qui fera reculer les
manifestants ici louis blouin radio
canada ottawa